yeah he'll when to welcome to this video
playing snooger are always playing with
blackens just doesn't exist any white
game against so these london clams and
the main thing is be quicker you will
play very quickly so I don't quite like
this a sick spawn here but he has played
a form and also not great already ever
told you that you don't trade minor
pieces and I QP position probably not
okay it was just a bit of a friend Liam
it's not so bad we can take d5 and
Bishop f3 actually I did not did not see
that I just want to be quick Ian because
its main goal in a game of chances to
win on time as I've learned over them
cause of our games
nope I did not see that beforehand
otherwise I would have avoided it but
it's not a big deal ultimately I hope I
don't see anything great for white
covering the e pawn
jump book see one or something lady but
I think this is pretty equal or maybe
you can do something with this
initiative that's possible it's really
possible i don't see it at the moment
but Luke see one looks like a normal
move 95 bishop is having something like
that is an idea nope you're training
minor pieces it's normally not a good
recipe in the iqp but ok why it is to a
reasonably actor so shouldn't shouldn't
be a huge issue firm
[Music]
I now it's not that it is not so easy to
avoid looks before this be sorry doesn't
help much ideal here is to get get the
Queen back so the book looks at in front
maybe can go 25 now no okay that wasn't
possible and now I'm threatening me five
it's difficult to play at six and d5 in
such a position I don't know it'd be
five does help probably not probably not
but maybe this is a way now that this
might still be a way to maybe come
around here with the heavy pieces to
infiltrate them just to infiltrate like
Queen and roock on the first rank
something like that could help
I know what has zero activity can just
shuffle around look at you Mellie was
the idea i don't i don't get enter with
the Queen unfortunately
tough tough to find a way forward can
try to put that on snag attending too
much or just plain mcdouble here for
Lucas e to this is something because d5
with a key on III he won't dare to play
I also think it doesn't look ok so let's
score for Lucas it too
looks it to a size is very serious
business so how can you survive this
tuition okay one there is no mate down
to p6 that's amazing will be when you
actually have covered
you're threatening here and we're gonna
take himself amazing check okay
checkmate okay so that sound okay I
think I always had could control them
over this I tell ya what stuff what
stuff somehow so this position okay so I
felt ya around here there were some
critical moment yeah but should be five
and now I don't think 96 I played a
plate too quickly i think it's held a
little bit awkward hem ok the consistent
doesn't find anything special but yeah
96 is the movie don't simply don't play
and no more normally why trade down why
not look see one or something keeping a
bit more pressure this is now going to
be extremely one-sided I just it can
pressurize the porn all the lights the
minor pieces are traded and yeah why
just might just have to suffer now now
I'm not sure I probably didn't play it
correctly really but yeah okay look bg5
google be five what is the same look
before they're not and queen d success
yeah this is probably not not clear but
this is losers ok quindi 6 I could have
played it was kind of an automatic move
but II five wins it is also win yeah
it's just to show too much yeah there
was a minute late and I was so tough at
the end somehow could easily blended it
away but in general it was a good
display while you don't trade all the
minor pieces in the IQ p.m. ok guys
thanks for watching